No, we got to we just got to start
asking. Let me bring up the next person.
I I gotta start asking them this
question actually. Ahmed, how you doing?
Hi. You're you're on stage, ma'am.
Welcome. Welcome to the panel. Sorry. Do
you um you're a Muslim, right? Yes. Do
you um do you love the Quran? Do I love
the Quran? Mhm.
Hello. What? You said you said no. Noah,
I asked you what's the question again? I
didn't hear it. Oh. Oh, I I asked, "Do
you love the Quran?" I sure do. Do you
cherish it? Yeah. Quick disclaimer
though before I continue. Uh I'm here to
talk about the other talking about the
Islamic dilemma, brother. Yeah. Yeah.
About about the Wait, let me tell you
this. Okay. Quick disclaimer before
this. My English isn't the best as you
can as you can see. We're talking about
how the Quran confirms the Bible,
brother. That's that's what we're
talking about today. Yeah. You you
talked about I just wanted to correct
you on something that you just said
about uh not you maybe David before you
uh talked about the Rome chapter chapter
3. We're about we're about the Islamic
dilemma today brother. Yeah but you say
some you say something wrong. You if you
if you make it past the Islamic dilemma
we'll allow you to correct chapter 30
vers4 on the Roman story. Okay fair
enough. I I I don't I didn't get in for
this group. Actually, my friend just
sent me. You don't think that you you
don't think you can solve the dilemma?
You don't think you can handle this
part? I don't think so. I know. Oh, I
don't have the enough knowledge. I wrong
to say that. I tell you what. Yeah, that
there's no problem. I'll tell you what.
Look, so this is what it says. The Quran
says that the previous scriptures are
true and it says that the Jews and
Christians have possession of them. They
have to judge by them. They have to
stand on them and they have to recite
them correctly. The Quran also
contradicts the previous scriptures in
several places like the crucifixion of
Jesus. Um Allah not being a father,
right? Stuff like that. Okay. Um
adultery, being able to commit adultery
with your slave girls, you know, sleep
with married women as long as they're
your slave women. So the Quran
contradicts the previous scriptures in
many ways while at the same time saying
that they're true. So that's the
problem. The Quran is false for
contradicting true scripture. If these
scriptures are corrupted, then the Quran
is still false because it's saying that
corrupted scripture is true. So that's
what the dilemma is. Okay. If you want,
watch our streams. We've we've been
going through this very thoroughly.
Watch my Friday streams. um and and and
you know pick up on it and see if you
can uh solve the dilemma. If not, leave
Islam and come to Christianity. Okay.
Yeah. About that, I just told you before
I really just came here. My friend just
sent me this link to this uh stream and
told me to just check it out. Then he
told me to I told him that what they say
what you guys said about the Rome
chapter is wrong because he got it out
of
contest and he asked me to join to
correct you guys. But I don't I don't
really have the as I told you before
enough knowledge on this so I can maybe
do some research and come back to you on
this topic. Okay. Yep. That's what we
want. I I want to have you back again
cuz I really do want to hear your
explanation of the of the Romans
chapter. So I but I at first I need to
hear how you handle this subject first.
Okay. Yeah. Well, I don't get the point
that you won't let me say anything about
the We did it with your friend as well.
We did that with your friend as well. We
talked about this and then he said,
"Hey, I have if he said even if you guys
are correct, I have other reasons why I
should believe in Islam." That's why we
went there afterwards cuz he he agreed
that this could be true, but he doesn't
think that it necessarily disproves
Islam. So, that's why he went to the
chapter of the Romans. Mhm. So, we we
that's why we allowed him to go there
cuz he said he has like a million
different other arguments for why Islam
is true. That's where he went because so
that's not our topic though. It's not
our topic because if the Islamic if no
one can answer it, it means your whole
Quran is false including the Romans and
all the other nonsense. So you have to
get through this first. You see what
you're saying? Sorry, I didn't hear you.
I said because if the Islamic dilemma is
true and you can't answer it or any
other Muslim, it means the whole Quran
is false including Romans and everything
else. Obviously people can't answer it.
Just not not me cuz I don't have the
right knowledge. No one can answer it.
No one. How do you know? No. How do you
say that? You did you interview
everyone? Yes, we we've been invited.
Yes. All your big dawa guys, they've
been all invited. Yeah. And they all
failed miserably. And even I even asked
to content. Who Who do you have YouTube
videos of that? Of course. Go. Can you
please send me a links for that please?
Our our streams are open. Our streams
are open. Yeah, it's fine. I just want
to go through all your channels. Don't
show up. If if you if you can give me
specific videos that I can see that uh
the famous uh scholars of Islam who are
famous scholars of Islam to you. I don't
really have a favorite. Just tell me
names. I'll tell you if so we we we
invited we've invited to this channel
specifically. We've invited a guy called
I think you maybe you spend more time on
the what's his name? Sad. He he's more
popular. Yeah. He's more popular on the
English uh section on YouTube. A lot of
these guys are we're we're talking but
you have like people like Ali Dawa all
these people they've been invited I know
I know Muhammad hijab and Ali Dawa yeah
do you have do you have debates with
them on this topic what we're saying is
they haven't come they've been invited
we've invited all these people to come
and even you you have knowledge about
don't have knowledge about this bigger
issue like saying it's only three four
verses it's not that I don't have
knowledge I do have knowledge I just
don't have the necessary knowledge for
it like give me give me has an argument
that I can't answer. None of there is no
answer to these. That's my point.
There's no answer to these arguments.
Yeah, it doesn't have an answer. That's
why you can't answer it. It's not
because of your lack of knowledge, by
the way. It's just you can't answer it.
And I understand because I can't answer
it. No one can answer it. If you can't
answer it, doesn't mean that it's not
being answered. Once again, I say find
the answer. When you find the answer,
Aladdin's lamp when you come. So, none
of the none of the Muslim scholars that
are famous that like Yeah. You said that
accepted your invite. None of them.
Yeah, none of them have come. None of
them. You I tell you what, you you
probably have access to some scholars.
Ask them to come. I know actually don't.
I can maybe like comment a new YouTube
video over there, but you don't have
access. No, not really. They have like I
can go on their YouTube channel and
leave a comment there, but I I
That's good enough. Yeah, that's good
enough. That can help. If you can do
that, that'd be great. Have them come
over to God Logic Apologetics. That'd be
great. They can come here just like
you're here right now. You know, we're
talking. They can come here and talk and
we can discuss it. Now, remember when
you leave the comment, make sure you let
them know that you are a Muslim who
visited this channel and you see that
we're running this argument and you
would like for them to come and answer
this cuz they're going to probably think
that you're maybe an undercover
Christian or something. So, let them be
clear that you're a Muslim brother. You
know, let them know say recite the fat
or something like that. Let them know
you're a Muslim brother.
and ask them if they can come and answer
and debunk the Islamic dilemma. Okay. I
might add uh one point though about this
topic actually. Okay. Okay. Surah in
Isa 46. Oh yeah. Pull this up on the
screen please. Yeah. Is it 46? Yeah.
446. We like that one. We like we like
the the next few verses too. It's pretty
good. What does it say? Oh, yep. Yep.
You didn't memorize this DLC. Oh, yeah.
We got it. I got it. I got it. I got it.
Y I forget his name. Sorry. It says,
"Among those who are Jews, there are
some who displace words from right
places and say, we hear your word and
disobey and hear and let you hear
nothing." and Ryena with a twist of
their tongues and as a mockery of their
religion. And if only they had said, "We
hear and obey and do make us
understand," it would have been better
for them and more proper, "But Allah has
cursed them from their disbelief." So
they believe not except a few. So you
see how it says that they twist with
their tongues. Actually the the the word
the verb
which is in
Arabic know what does that mean? Yeah.
What does that mean? That means that
they if you actually look up the own
translation of the word it says changing
the name the changing the subject
changing changing the text. Yeah. No is
change changing the words. Yeah.
Changing the words from their from their
places. Yeah. Mother correct? Yeah.
Okay. Does it And then it
goes. What does mean? Just give me a
moment.
Okay. I'm going to help for everyone
else who doesn't know
Arabic mean twisting with their tongues.
Yeah.
You you agree with this? Does you agree
with Means twisting with the tongue?
Does it say in the translation that you
just read? Okay. You know Arab, right?
Yes, I do. What does mean their tongues?
Thank you. So they're changing the words
with their tongue and we know it's all
tongues because he
says what does mean? Okay. But wait wait
wait wait wait. What does mean for the
people who don't know Arabic who are
listening to us? They are saying not
they're writing. They're changing
something with the words with the tongue
saying. Can you find me anywhere in this
verse? It says they they took something
with a hand and wrote it in the text. If
but can you accept? No, no, wait. Wait.
Can you can you accept? I accept they
change someone I accept they change
right because I can change something in
the Quran right now. I can twist with
the tongue something for my Quran right
now. Does it mean the Quran is changed
in the paper? No. Because you have like
millions millions of people that
memorize the Quran. Exactly. So that's
what it says here. And if you go to the
commentaries, the commentaries tell you
that this is about their
interpretations. Right. Yeah. We can put
it up for you if you want. It says in
the they change their
meaning and they change the
interpretation. It does not say they
change it on the paper in the text. But
if someone if someone changes the with
their orally like with their mouth. Y
what what will prevent them from change
it with the text? But that's not what it
says. That's not what it says. Yeah.
Then you have to prove to me that any
anywhere else from your Quran that they
change it in the text because I can do
the same in the Quran right now. I can
change something with my tongue. I can
go around say lies about Quran. For me
to prove that the Quran is corrupted by
on the text in the paper I have to show.
But you can't but you can't really do
that because as I said for me and they
were cory. Exactly. So people will
correct me. So, how do you know that
other people other yeood or anyone else
didn't correct them? There were lots of
Jews all around the world, lots of Torah
all around the world and uh angels all
around the world. Just because in Arabia
some people changed something with the
tongue, Allah told them off, don't do
that. Doesn't mean anything is corrupted
anywhere. And by the way, look at the
very next verse. Thank you. Yeah, this
is what Avery was talking about earlier.
The very next verse, what does it say,
Ahmed? The very next verse. Can you show
it to me on top of it? I got it. It's on
the screen. It's Oh you who have been
given the scripture, right? The Jews and
the Christians. Yeah. Believe in what we
have
revealed, confirming what is already
with you. Ah, so what's with them isn't
corrupted. It's it's being confirmed.
Oh, okay. Yeah. It says in the next
verse so he how can he
say if it corrupts confirming what is
with you if it they changed it in the
paper on the text in the paper. Okay. As
I told you before I can't
really knowledge. Yeah. I have one more.
Okay. Yeah. Sorry. Show you how strong
we're showing you how we're showing you
how strong this argument is from the
your Quran itself. Go ahead. Go ahead,
sister. Your Quran says stop twisting
your words with it. Stop concealing it.
Stop hiding it. Stop teaching the people
wrong. Follow what you have. That's what
I mean. Follow what? Yeah. Follow what
you have. That
mean what has been revealed. Revealed.
No, it says it says what is with you
now? What is with them now? What's with
you now? That was revealed before to
them by Moses or Jesus.
So they have but after that after after
Yeah. after they have the revelation of
Jesus and Moses. They have it with them.
That's what the Quran says. Yeah, that's
right. As soon as uh the revelation went
on Jesus and Moses themselves, the
either it's in the Old Testament or the
New Testament, both of them were fine.
Both of them were actually the word of
God. We believe in that. Okay. What
about Muhammad's son? What about
Muhammad? One sec. Let me let me finish,
please. what what they don't what they
uh what we don't believe in which is the
that they has been preserved probably
cuz after the after they have been uh
revealed they probably have been uh
tempered with you said probably you said
probably not sure then so so I'm sure
that they will have been tempered with
walk walk this walk with me here if
they've been corrupted if they've been
tampered with then when the Quran says
in Muhammad's time talking to Jews and
Christians in Muhammad's time that they
need to believe in the Quran which
confirms what they have with them means
that the Quran is confirming corrupted
scripture. Is that what you mean? Is
that what the Quran's doing? No. As I as
I said before, if someone has orally
made that it's right that it didn't uh
how can it be how can it be with them if
it's oral? It's with them in a in a book
the book. They're not called the people
of the oral. Yeah, but they the book is
it a book? Is it a book or not? It
literally says they've been given the
scripture. They've been given the book.
They were given the not the oral.
They've been given the book and the
Quran came confirming what they have.
What is with them? Yep. Yep. So what
they have, the Quran is saying it's
true. But you're saying no, no, no, no,
no. What they have is actually tampered
with. So who should we go with? You or
the Quran? the Quran obviously you make
a good point as I said before and this
is my limited knowledge I will have to
research this but brother I mean I I
take you as a guy who is able to to be
intellectually consistent like I I
believe you can be honest here if if
from what we're seeing from what the
Quran says like just what we showed you
so far the Quran is pretty clear so far
at least that what they have is not
corrupted right again I said I can't
really make. How do I say this in
Arabic? In English, I can't really say
100%. For this cuz I didn't look this
up. As I told you before, I came here
for a different knowledge about just
correcting you about
the Do you read the Quran? I do read the
Quran. Yeah, I know. I'm just asking
you, brother. Just from what we've went
over so far, I know that you don't know
the topic in in its totality, but just
what you've seen so far, it's it's
pretty clear so far that the scriptures
they have in Muhammad's time are not
corrupted, right? They're true from what
we see so far, right? Are we talking
about as soon as they they got revealed
or like the current Torah? We're talking
about the current Torah and gospel
that's with the Jews and Christians
according to what the Quran is saying
right here on the screen. When it says
it's confirming what they have, what's
with them? Just give me a moment. If the
Quran is confirming what is with them,
that means that what is with them is not
tampered with. Right. Just give it a
little moment. One moment, please. You
guys, this is what happens when you
believe your da guys over the Quran.
This is why I asked, do you guys love
the Quran, man? Exactly. like they go
against your Quran. All this corrupted
business is going against. It's Yeah,
it's crazy cuz like we're just reading
the Quran and like we're not giving you
something that like this is like oh what
something Christians wrote. We're say
hey believe this. We're going to your
Quran like this is what you're supposed
to believe in. Like we're not go we're
giving you something else. This is the
Quran. Yeah. And just for your
information, since you're going to be
researching this, if you read all the
earliest ones,
um, even like Sadi
and none of them say this corrupted
business, this corruption business that
they all been telling us since we were
little, is new. They've been saying it
for 100 or so years. I don't know how
long, but it's not in the old books, not
in the Quran, and not in the years. And
it's new because now with the everybody
having the Bible available and people
are not as illiterate as they used to
be, everyone can see what the what the
Bible says is against the Quran. That's
why they said, "Oh, it must be changed
then cuz they believe Muhammad." But
what Muhammad has been saying from the
beginning is a lie. The Quran does not
confirm the Bible because it's opposite
books. That's your dilemma. Okay, that's
a fair point. It it's it's it's true. Um
like we we we've gone through all the
taps. None of them say of it is corrupt
any of them. Most most scholars say
including Iban
Cathed as I said before this verse shows
that some parts of the Torah were still
intact. No. No. Where does it say some?
What do you mean? What do you mean some?
It doesn't say some. It doesn't say
some. We can we can show it to you right
now um if you want. it. I've never I've
never seen the sum and parts because the
Quran actually condemns saying parts are
true and the other parts are false. It
condemns that. Yeah. Like in 85 it says
verse 85 verse
85. Yeah, I know this and it's talking
about the Torah. So it can't be parts
correct and parts not that we're talking
about Muhammad of course. Yeah. The
problem is Yeah. The problem with this
dilemma
is just because one the Torah for
example or the New Testament align with
the Quran doesn't actually mean that
we're believing in in a half of it
because if it's automatically if if we
as Muslims believe that the Quran is
100% true and someone comes with a book
doesn't mean matter if it's an Old
Testament or New Testament or not not
even a religion book if someone comes
with a book and says that this is true
and in the Quran says that this is the
same context and we were talking about
the same thing and it's actually true
that doesn't just that doesn't make it
doesn't say that we're uh believing in
the book itself. Yeah, but the Quran
tells you to believe in the books though
the Quran tells you believe in the
books. We believe in the we believe in
the books itself that have been uh
revealed to Yeah. You believe you Moses
and Jesus. You you believe in like some
some theory books that don't even exist.
Like these are like books that no one
has ever seen before. Like like books
that Yeah. Yeah. Like you're saying like
these are we believe in books but nobody
has ever seen them. They don't exist
today but we believe in them. Like it
doesn't make any sense. I can't tell you
I believe in the Quran and then you show
me hey uh this is what the Quran says.
Do you believe this? I say no no no. I
said I believe in the Quran that was
originally revealed but not this one.
And and you're saying no no this is the
Quran. This is the Quran. And I'm like,
"No, no. I told you I believe in the
Quran, but I don't believe what you
have." That's not the Quran. It doesn't
make sense. It means I don't really
believe in anything. So, you basically
believe in books you've never seen.
That's your issue. They don't exist.
What the Quran says is that these books
exist in Muhammad's time and they cannot
be they cannot be changed. They cannot
be corrupted. Yeah. And like the text
cannot change. Allah's words cannot be
changed. Yeah. Said that's that's
another problem you have. Quran says
many time at least a couple of times
Yeah. that there's no changing Allah's
words and Allah as you agree his words
are in the Torah at least originally. So
now we have a problem because Allah says
no one changed his words and now you say
they've been changed so you can't agree
with me. So, so right, so did Allah
either Allah lied to you when he said
that no one can change his words because
his words include the Torah and the
gospel remember or he promised and he
allowed weak humans with their hands to
break his promise right that's a fair
point of view to make of course it is
you know you know it because when I your
Quran is actually you're my biggest
weapon against you and that's and that's
your dilemma you can't bring me the
Bible and say and do the same thing on
But I can bring you the Quran to prove
to you either your Allah really wanted
to preserve it and he's weak and he
didn't preserve it or he lied to you or
he preserved it and when he and if he
preserved it you say it doesn't exist
today then you're stuck. Yep. Okay. Uh
the Quran actually never denies that
some truth remains in it doesn't say
some truth. It says like where does it
say? Yeah. Yeah. And what just do you
love the Quran? I'm not the Quran. Okay.
So if you love the Quran, you ne you
will never add to what the Quran says,
right? I want to see some truths,
please. You you will never add. Yeah.
Where so the Quran can you where are you
getting this some truths from? Some part
where you getting this from? Sorry.
Where are you getting this idea that
there are still there are some truths of
the Torah and the Gospel remaining, but
not all not all of it. Where do you get
that from? Does the Quran say that? From
the Quran itself. It doesn't say
actually some just give me a second.
Give me a second please. The Quran never
denies that there are there is some
truth remaining in earlier books. In
fact, in 546 in 546 47 I'm sorry. The
angel contains guidance and light.
Ahmed. Does it say it contains some
guidance and some light? No. But it has
guidance and light and period, right?
Yeah. And after it has been changed, it
doesn't say no. No reason to
other verses that you get. You you were
reading chapter you're reading uh 56
and you said that in is the is guidance
and light and then what's the very next
line that comes after that
so the angel has guidance and light and
it confirms what's with it in the its
hands from the Torah. So where is sum
and sum of there's no s and sum there's
no s and sum anywhere. In fact, it says
it's guidance and light. That's like
perfect in there's in other verses, not
in this. Uh that's the one you brought
us. You brought you brought this. Yeah,
I brought this. Yeah, I brought this
one. But it doesn't help. It doesn't
help you, does it? Doesn't say the sum
and some you said. A give us a verse
where it says that there's some truths
in the Torah and Gospel. Okay. Here's
another verse in No, no, not another.
Give us one. Cuz this one didn't work.
So, it's not another verse. It's you're
about to give us actually something.
Okay. Okay. If you want to. Okay. Okay,
no problem.
In Surah 13
verse No,
sorry. Verse 13. Yeah. Okay. What does
it say? Verse 41. What does it say? Oh,
sorry. Give me a second. It's okay.
It's the same very similar language of
446. But let's let's go through the
Arabic now here because I'm glad that he
know he knows Arab. We can go through
the Arab. Ahmed, are you still there?
Yeah. Yeah. Just give me one, please.
Trying to pull it up. Y'all don't love
y'all's Quran, man. No, they don't. They
really don't. They don't. You guys will
add to your Quran. You'll take
away ignore the Quran. Y'all hate it.
I'm I'm convinced the Quran. What do you
mean hate it? I read it every day. No,
but you don't love it, though. Okay. I
read it in first in Arabic.
Okay. So, where is it? Where is your
evidence? Okay. The same thing as the
same thing. Does that Does that remind
you does that remind you of something?
This this phrase does it remind you of
something? The verse that was just g
gave it to you.
The verse before where it said, do you
remember that? Exactly the same. They
change the words from their places. Does
that mean the text is changed? Second.
One second. Well, we can go to the
commentary as well. We can go to right
now and tell you what he said about
this. Do you want to know? Shall we put
it up? We put it up.
Sure. Every's got it in English, but
I've got Arabic as well. If you want
what
what he means he
says their understanding became
corrupt. Okay. Wait. Were you reading?
I'm reading. Yeah. Can you pull? I can
pull it up if you want. He wants the You
want You want the Arabic? Let's go. All
right. You see here? No, he can't. He's
I was I was going to pull up the Arabic,
but y'all got it. Yeah, man. Yeah. Yeah.
We we'll get we'll we'll get here. We
got we got here. You see here? Yeah.
Okay. Just zoom we'll zoom in a little
bit on zoom in a little bit on the
Arabic just so you can read it better.
Mhm.
In the blue change the words from their
places. What does that mean? Their
understanding became
corrupt. They mishandled the ayat the
verses of Allah.
They interpreted his book different to
what he
revealed. Huh? And
they basically did what it was not
intended. Tell me where here where says
they changed they applied it. Yeah. In a
way that's not intended. Tell me where
here where it says it changed the text.
Even here it
says you see here they forgot a part of
what they were reminded of.
They left. They neglected abandoned
acting on it. Which means that they had
the ability to act on it if they wanted
to. So they didn't. But they had the
ability to do so. That means the people
were bad. Not that the book is
corrupted. Their understanding is bad,
their interpretation is bad, their
application is bad. Where does it say
here from? Yeah. But but if if their
interpretation is bad and their wait one
sec. Yeah. if their introduction is bad
and they they as I said before they did
it orally and when so imagine imagine
like
there let's say let's say like the Shia
for example they have the same Quran
that you're reading they're going to
interpret it according to you in a wrong
way right in a very wrong way so you're
going to say you wouldn't say that the
Quran is wrong because of how they're
interpreting you say interpretation is
wrong exactly so so so this is not
saying that the book is wrong. It's just
saying that the how they're interpreting
it is wrong. They're bad and they're not
acting on it the right way. Their action
is bad.
One second. If they say, what does that
mean? They left acting on it, right?
That means that it the book is good. It
just the actions are are not It's just
that they left it. Okay. Uh this verse
is talking is that correct? You're not
you're not you're not focusing. Do you
hear the last line? What does it say?
Correct. What does that mean? They
didn't do by the book. Exactly. That
does that mean the book is good or bad?
The book itself is good. Thank you. And
who's bad here? Who's who's bad here?
The people? The people or the
people? Thank you. That means the book
is good. The book is good. The book is
not corrupted because otherwise they he
wouldn't say because they should they
should they should they should leave it
if it's corrupt. But the book is good.
If if you make a generation that has
been doing this corrupt corrupting the
book with their uh and not doing doing
the right thing not doing by the book
and they come up with the new uh uh
gospels which is Mark
no they didn't come up with the new
gospels and by the way what about the
gospels the four gospels they just
misinterpreted yeah by by the way the
Quran also speaks about a group it
speaks about a group that uh do not like
exchange the words of Allah for a small
price. It says that they're they're
righteous and they're good. Like for
example 3:1 199 uh there's a people
among the people of the scripture are
those who believe in Allah and what was
revealed to you and what was revealed to
them and they're submissive to Allah.
They do not exchange the verses of Allah
for a small price.
Yeah. Exactly. So there were a good
group of people from these Christians
and Jews. So there there are ones who
are following it and they're ones who
weren't following it. So what you said
is you might have a generation disagree
with that right? What yeah yeah so what
you're saying is you might have a
generation of people who who don't
follow it and who are bad and you think
that okay they might corrupt the cor the
books over time even though it doesn't
say that but guess what there's also the
good and they kept the book and they
followed the book exactly just like any
generation. Yeah. And how would some
people follow? Just like any generation,
some people follow and some people
don't. Some people are good and some
people are bad. At the time, Allah says
those who don't follow don't and who
don't who who sell it for a small price
are bad. Those who do are good. So how
is the book how is the book corrupted at
all? So the book's not at fault. It's
the people. Okay, one second. So my
point is how do we know who are the bad
people or the good people that follow
Jesus and Moses if let me finish because
the Quran tells us the Quran can I
finish my sentence please? Well you
asked a question the Quran answers I
didn't I didn't I didn't finish the
question. Okay go ahead. Go ahead. Thank
you. If we we said that there's wrong
people and bad people. I don't uh sorry
bad people and good people. I don't
disagree with that. How do we know that
the the gospels that has been written
after Jesus has died because we like
Mark, Luke, John and uh fourth one I
always forget it. How do we know who
these people are? If they was if they
were the good people or the bad people
if we don't even know where who they
are. We don't even know their second
name, let alone her. Yeah, we first of
all we do. But secondly, can you show
them to me please? Can you give me a
reference? Yeah. Yeah. John the son of
Zebedee for example. Okay. This is this
is not I know this is what you're told
like the the Dawa people they tell you
this. This is not true. We have their
names. We have their families. We know
who you know Peter son of Simon. Like we
this is not we're not this is not like
something that we don't know. We know
this. But that doesn't matter. The point
is is that the Quran tells you that you
know who the followers of Jesus are
because they're going to be uppermost.
They're going to be above the other
people. Do you know that verse? Sorry.
What's the verse? Yeah.
it. Yeah. 355 355. It actually it
actually the the Quran actually gives a
promise that the people who follow Jesus
will be uppermost above the
disbelievers. Yeah.
Yeah. I am I am making those who follow
you meaning the real you know what you
call the real Jesus whatever above the
disbelievers until judgment day. So that
means the the biggest group, the most
victorious group, the always had the
four gospels. Yeah. The most visible
group are always going to be above the
the the disbelievers until judgment day.
That mean includes today because notice
the very next verse. Allah says and
those who disbelieve the ones who you
know don't believe are going to give
them a very harsh in this world and in
the hereafter and they shall have no
helpers. So if the punishment is in this
world and in the hereafter, well guess
what? These small groups that you know
you might say, "Oh, this group or that
group, these hierarchics or these
heretics, guess what? They had a bad
punishment in this life and in the next
life." But the ones who are victorious,
the ones who are, you know, conquer and
victorious and they're the popular,
that's the ones who we have to this is
this is the group today. These are the
Christians from from the very beginning
who had the same Bible that we have
today. That's that's why we have the
book because they're victorious, right?
If they weren't victorious, we wouldn't
have the Bible. Some other would have,
right? But we it's it's it's a world
it's a promise in this world, not just
in the afterlife, but in this world
because the punishment is in this world
as well. Yeah. So, it can't be that the
real of Jesus just a small group and
they disappeared. No, your
says until judgment day, they will be
uppermost victorious, you know.
you know, victorious. Yeah, that that I
understand. Okay. So, it can't be that,
you know, they're just disappeared or
whatever and and what we have today is
not them that we had before. They
disappear. I just didn't I just say that
we can't really make sure these are the
good people or the you you can't be sure
because you're Allah and your Quran
doesn't tell you, but we are sure. No,
it does tell you. It does tell you. It
tells you that they're going to be the
ones above. They're going to be the
victorious ones. So, the true followers
of Jesus are going to be the victorious.
followers. Yeah. That that was Jesus
that they that we believe that will we
also believe that they will go to heaven
because they they followed the prophet
of the of their time. Yeah. Everyone
that follows the prophet of his time is
a successful person that will go to the
It says no it says so from the time of
Jesus until the day of resurrection this
group is going to be victorious. Okay.
They're going to be uh above the people
who disbelieved. Okay. So this group we
can identify them. We know who they are
and we know what Bible they had. It's
the same Bible we have today because
they're victorious. These are the ones
who God preserved. Yeah. And the Quran
actually says that as well that Allah
preserves them. We don't believe that,
you know, the Quran is correct here.
That Allah is actually saying like
inspiring this, but we're saying this is
true. Allah God really did preserve the
true Christians and he preserved our
Bible. This is what your book says too
though. So you're stuck with this. So
that's how you can identify the true.
Like you said, okay, I agree that
there's good and I agree there's bad. So
you're like, "How do you identify the
good ones?" Well, they're the ones who
are going to be victorious. Yeah. And if
they don't think that Yeah. And if you
don't think they're victorious, that
means again your Allah promised
something. How How do you know that
they're victorious though? Well, what
does Fala mean? I know what fa means.
It's above like above. Exactly. So where
is this great group that is above?
Because until German day because we we
see what they're in their graves either.
Right. But you see in the ne you see in
the next verse the very next verse verse
56 it tells you what happens to the
disbelievers the ones who disbelieve
that they're going to have a very bad
punishment and torture the in this day
and the hereafter. Yeah exactly. So so
in other words in this life they're
going to suffer and in the next life
they're going to suffer. Right. So it's
happening in the world. We can see it in
the world today. So whatever group of
Christians that existed that were like
you know suff like you know they they
had this punishment from God on them
they didn't exist well those ones you
can say okay they didn't they don't
exist anymore but the ones who continue
to exist those are the ones that are
like these are the ones so you're
assuming because they're not being
punished right now
in that's just because they not being
punished right now and you don't see
them getting punished that these are the
victorious quote unquote Christians
Well, it does. It does. Your issue is
here. The it says, "Yeah, this is who
Allah ch this is who Allah preserved."
Like these are the majority of
Christians until judgment day. So, it's
not just at the time of Jesus that he
made them victorious. Complete the verse
though. Complete the verse. Yeah. It
says,
"Okay." Okay. So, what is here yet? No.
But after
until God will judge them on the day of
judgment, then he will decide. They will
go. Yes. then he will decide that's
fine. So until judgment day, which is
the day we are living today, the real
followers of Jesus are above and the
ones who aren't are suffering in this
like they're dying out. They're not
they're not continuing to exist. All
right. So we are living it now unless
Allah's lied. They're living it. Being
punished doesn't necessarily mean that
they're gone. Well, right now we didn't
say they're gone. They said we're being
they're punished. But let's like their
message. What we're saying is the
message is not going to be overcoming
the other message. It's going to be
small compared to the other one because
the other one's going to be bigger. So
either it dies out or it's just not
never going to be as big. But the point
is is that the victorious one, the good
one is always going to be the biggest
one until judgment day. So we're living
this now and we know who is the biggest
Christian groups. What are the ones who
It's exactly what we have to the ones
that believe father, son, holy spirit
and that Jesus was crucified from the
dead which is exactly what they believed
at the time. And we know that the time
of Muhammad when we know that because
the people of Najan they were all
Christians and they went and they said
the same thing to him and they did mub
with him. No they did actually he wanted
to do mubhal with them but they believed
back then what we believe now and they
were the ones who are uppermost until
judgment day. So either Allah lied or he
broke his promise. He never lies or bros
his promise. Exactly. So I I actually
believe Allah in this one. I actually
believe Allah in this one or what
Muhammad wrote in this one. It's true
that the God of the Bible, the real
Christians, the real Christians are
still are still above. We're preserved
and and have the superior and we have
the superior message. And how many
Christians are in the world now? What do
you mean Muhammad wrote? What's that?
Yeah, I believe Muhammad wrote I don't
believe it's from Allah. But anyway, how
how did he wrote it? How did he
It's another issue. But my point is
Yeah, you can just pull out a wrong fact
and tell me that it's another issue. It
came out of his mouth and people wrote
it later. So what he wrote it came it
came from his imagination. That's my
point. But my point is what he said here
is true that the true Christians are
superior. God preserved them their
message their you know we it doesn't say
the Bible but their Bible what they
believed in until they're the ones who
are preserved. Yes. Okay. So anyway that
that's the that's it. So you have a lot
you have a lot to kind of like look back
on. You can Yeah, that's fine. I I
really appreciate you guys for letting
me join you and talk to you and this has
been really I really actually enjoyed
this. Yeah, it's good talking to you
really. It's good. Thanks a lot for this
and a small question just for a personal
question if you don't mind answering.
For how long have you been Muslim? Her
whole life. Yeah, my whole life. Like as
soon as you Oh, okay. You grew in a
Muslim household? You born in a Muslim
and how how old how old how old how old
how old how old how old how old how old
how old how old are you now? No, no, we
we're not going to tell that. I ask a
woman how old she is. Ask the woman how
old. No, not you. You can't answer us.
We're We're just joking with you. But
yeah. Yes. She's been a Muslim until
like recently recently in her life
years. Like recently in her life. A few
years. Okay. Okay. Thank you guys very
much. I will probably come back to you
as soon as like I get more knowledge
about this.
Once again, thank you all. Uh I really
appreciate this conversation.
Thanks a lot. And that's it. Take care
Ahmed. Take care. You and your friend.
Thank you. Yeah. Actually, this friend
was really good to talk to as well. So,
like good people. Just It's just the
Dawa, man. It's just the DA. Yeah. The
the friend you mentioned that said that
that gave you the link. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Tell them tell him we
said hello as well. No problem. Okay. I
never